♪♪
.
>> Sean: ALRIGHT BIG NEWS
TONIGHT OUT OF CAPITOL HILL,
SENATE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM DEMANDING ANSWERS
ON THE FBI FROM THE THIRD
INFAMOUS RAID, IN THIS CASE
ROGER STONE'S HOME IN FLORIDA.
WHY DID THE FBI SEND 27 AGENTS
ARMED WITH RIFLES, BODY ARMOR TO
ARREST STONE FOR LYING TO
CONGRESS?
HE'S NOT EL CHAPO.
THE SENATOR WANTS TO KNOW IF CNN
WAS TIPPED OFF BY THE MUELLER
TEAM TO GET THE EXCLUSIVE
FOOTING OF THIS RAID.
JOINING US WITH BREAKING NEWS,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
>>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK THAT WAS
ABOUT ABORTION IN THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA
>>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: YOU ONCE SPONSORED A
BILL THAT I AGREE WITH
>>> I HAVE IT RIGHT NOW.
HOW MANY NATIONS ALLOW ABORTION
ON DEMAND AFTER 20 WEEKS, WHICH
IS THE FIFTH MONTH?
SEVEN.
SEVEN NATIONS IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD ALLOW ABORTION ON DEMAND
AFTER 20 WEEKS.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT ABORTION
DURING THE ACTUAL BIRTHING.
SO MY BILL SAYS, UNLESS THERE'S
LIFE OF THE MOTHER IS AT STAKE,
AS A RESULT OF RAPE OR INCEST
YOU CAN'T HAVE ABORTION ON
DEMAND IN THE FIFTH MONTH.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS --
>> Sean: YOU WOULD HAVE FOUR
MONTHS TO DECIDE
>>> MOST AMERICANS WOULD BE FINE
WITH THAT.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO THIS
LETTER, AND I WILL BE HONEST, I
KIND OF EXPECT AND HAVE EXPECTED
MORE OUT OF DIRECTOR WRAY.
UNDER JAMES COMEY WE HAVE TWO
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS ONGOING,
I THINK THERE SHOULD BE FAR
MORE.
WE HOPEFULLY WILL GET TO THAT.
YOU HAVE SAID YOU WILL GET INTO
THIS.
TALK ABOUT WHAT SHOULD HE DO?
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS TO PEOPLE
FOR PROCESS CRIMES?
WHY DOESN'T IT HAPPEN TO ALL THE
LIBERALS LIKE CLAPPER, BREB
LIBERALS LIKE CLAPPER, BRENNAN,
MILLS, ABEDIN, ALL THESE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE LIED TO CONGRESS?
WHY NOT THE PRE DAWN RAID
>>> MY JOB IS TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
LOVE THE FBI, RESPECT THEM, BUT
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO WATCH THOSE
WHO WATCH US.
I'M GONNA TELL YOU ALL I CAN
ABOUT THE FISA WARRANT AND HOW
THEY USED THE UNVERIFIED DOSSIER
PAID FOR BY A POLITICAL PARTY
WITHOUT ANY VERIFICATION.
>> Sean: RUSSIAN LIES
>>> YEAH, I WANT TO KNOW WHY TO
EXECUTE A SEARCH WARRANT WITH
SOMEBODY WHO HAD A LAWYER, THE
BEST WAY TO GET ROGER STONE IS
TO TELL HIM, CNN WANTS TO TALK
TO YOU, HE'LL SHOW UP WHENEVER
YOU WANT HIM TO SHOW UP.
>> Sean: OUCH
>>> THIS SEEMS TO ME OVER THE
TOP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MESSAGE
WAS, BEING SENT.
BUT I PERSONALLY DIDN'T LIKE IT.
I'VE BEEN A PROSECUTOR, DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, IT SEEMED TO BE
SENDING THE WRONG MESSAGE.
THAT IF YOU CROSS MUELLER, LOOK
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO YOU.
MUELLER, DO YOUR JOB.
BUT THESE TACTICS ARE
UNACCEPTABLE, GIVEN THE LEVEL OF
THREAT HERE
>> Sean: I LOOK AT HIS TEAM.
HE HAS A CLINTON FOUNDATION
ATTORNEY, ONLY DEMOCRATIC
DONORS, NO REPUBLICAN DONORS AND
THE MAN WHO WAS EXCORIATED FOR
WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ENRON EMPLOYEES LOST THEIR JOB,
HE LOST 9-0 IN THE SUPREME
COURT.
HE'S THE LEAD GUY
>>> IF THEY'RE SENDING A
MESSAGE, I'M SENDING A MESSAGE
TO THEM.
YOU'RE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
CONGRESS.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT
>> Sean: YOU WILL GET TO THIS?
>>> THEY BETTER ANSWER MY
LETTER, IF I WERE THEM I WOULD
>> Sean: WE'LL GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IDENTIFY SACHLT SOMEBODY
SIGNED OFF ON SOMETHING THEY
DIDN'T VERIFY
>>> PUT IT THIS WAY.
WHAT IF THE ROLLS WERE REVERSED?
WHAT IF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HIRED A FORMER BRITISH AGENT TO
GO TO RUSSIA TO DIG UP DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON AND EVERYTHING
IN THE DOSSIER WAS A BUNCH OF
BS, DO YOU THINK THAT MIGHT BE
FRONT PAGE NEWS EVERYWHERE ALL
THE TIME?
>> Sean: THE GRASSLEY GRAHAM
MEMOS, BULK OF INFORMATION, THAT
MEANS THEY COMMITTED A FRAUD ON
A COURT AND THEY NEVER TOLD THE
COURT.
I HAVE TO GET TO IMMIGRATION
>>> OKAY.
>> Sean: A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES
LOOKED AT DONALD TRUMP, NEW YORK
BUSINESSMAN, DONATED TO
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, AT
ONE POINT WAS ACTUALLY PRO
CHOICE.
HE'S PRO-LIFE NOW
>>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: HE KEPT HIS PROMISES ON
JUDGES, TAXES, REGULATIONS,
ENERGY, NOW HE'S TRYING TO FIGHT
FOR THE WALL.
I TOLD PEOPLE THEN HE'S GOING TO
GOVERN AS ALE CONSERVATIVE.
SOME DOUBTED ME.
I THINK I'VE BEEN PROVEN RIGHT.
AND I WOULD SAY NOW I'M 99%
CERTAIN, EITHER THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT BUDGET OR EMERGENCY
MONEY IS GOING TO BE USED AND
HE'S RETHE LENTLESS AND
TENACIOUS AND CHANGING STRATEGY
IS NOT LOSING
>>> WE'RE GOING TO BUILD THE
WALL ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
I JUST TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT
TEN MINUTES BEFORE I CAME ON
YOUR SHOW.
>> Sean: I KNOW FOR A FACT, IT
WAS IN THE GREEN ROOM
>>> $5.7 BILLION REPRESENTS TEN
LOCATIONS ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
THAT A BARRIER WOULD MAKE THE
MOST DIFFERENCE.
IT'S A PROFESSIONALLY DESIGNED
PLAN.
IF YOU LOOK IT AT THE TEN
LOCATIONS ON THE BORDER WHERE
THE PROFESSIONALS SAY WE NEED A
BARRIER IT ADDS UP TO
5.7 BILLION.
EVER DEMOCRAT VIRTUALLY HAS
VOTED FOR 634 MILES OF FENCING.
WHEN YOU ASK PEOPLE WHERE THE
TEN LOCATIONS OF 634 MILES WE
NEED SOMETHING UP NOW, THEY GAVE
US THE LOCATION AND THE PRICE
TAG IS 5.7 BILLION.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT DOING
ANYTHING CRAZY.
WHAT'S CRAZY IS THAT THEY'RE
FIGHTING HIM AFTER HAVING VOTED
THE WAY THEY DID IN THE PAST.
>> Sean: JUST IN THE OBAMA, A
FEW YEARS AGO
>>> YES.
FEBRUARY 2018.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT OFFERED
THINGS DEMOCRATS DREAMED ABOUT
>>> LET ME TELL YOU, HERE IS THE
CONVERSATION.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO WORK WITH
DEMOCRATS.
HE DOESN'T -- THE SHUTDOWN IS
NOT THE WAY TO GET A RESULT.
ED IT BECAUSE HE HAD NOBODY TO
WORK WITH.
DEMOCRATS ARE OVER PLAYING THEIR
HAND.
IF YOU WANT TPS REFORM AND DACA
REFORM.
YOU'LL GET IT BUT YOU WON'T GET
IT IF HE DOES IT BY HIMSELF.
>> Sean: I'M WORRIED ABOUT YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
>>> I'M WORRIED, TOO.
IF YOU DON'T STAND BY THIS
PRESIDENT -- EVERY PRESIDENT,
BUSH, OBAMA AND TRUMP SENT
TROOPS TO THE BORDER.
WHAT IS UNUSUAL ABOUT THAT?
NOTHING.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SENDING A TROOP TO SECURE THE
BORDER AND BUILD A BARRIER WHILE
THEY'RE THERE?
HE HAS ALL THE POWER TO DO THIS.
TO MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES,
STAND BEHIND HIM.
>> Sean: EXACTLY.
IT'S GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY